serge gainsbourg et bien j'en ai appris
des choses sur vous grâce à la coelho et
franck lhomeau pour les textes et nadine
costa pour les photographier dans un
album intitulé tout simplement
gainsbourg aux éditions denoël attention
quand je dis album ici et apostrophe
c'est bien un album et c'est bien livre
parce que dans des émissions variété un
album c'est un 33 tours double album
trop alors là il s'agit vraiment d'un
livre et d'un très beau livre très beau
lire les photos sont superbes et les
textes sont à fait intéressant réside
alors par exemple une chose que j'ai
apprise au genou gauche je connais vous
connaissez peut-être pas très bien il ya
des gens qui vous connaissent mieux
point enfin j'ai appris par exemple que
votre première ambition votre premier
talent c'était la peinture ça j'étais
très très surpris à quel âge 28 ans même
assez assez tard oui non mais jusqu'à
vous avez qu'il était le genre de
peinture que faisait gainsbourg est doux
de dessin j'étais craintif
je pense que bismes sionisme combien de
révision en très peu d'années tout ça
alors lui qui sillonneront les routes
initiez-vous les peintures et suite je
suis passé ça s'appelle une initiation
un art majeur devant une initiation pas
un art mineur parce que les gones
économies que nous faisons nous mais
quelle est pour le surréalisme qui vous
avez rien mais si le syndicat mekhissi à
leurs abonnés a annoncé béart qui te
parle mais on pense que ces mineurs une
chanson sans kouici l'inertie me gardner
situera que la peinture n'a pas besoin
d'initiation pour la chanson qu'elle
soit des initiations pour la pinte pour
les arts majeurs l'architecturé la
peinture et la musique classique et la
littérature et la poésie le easy s'il te
plaît ne faisons pas de la poésie
non il n'ya pas d'art mineur et ce n'est
pas la peine ça la chanson dans ces
mineurs sinon je ne serais pas là tu
peux te coûte est important même la
cuisine c'est un supporter du pognon sur
le pauvre servier mois serge gainsbourg
toutes vos chansons qu'on dirait que ce
sont des choses mais alors absolument
c'est vrai sauf certaines qui ont frôlé
la mission propose sur un beau certaines
certaine c'est qu'elle est le dieu
dessus du jeune mais le dilemme se
souvienne je l'emmenais dernière chanson
de charles trenet de djendel alors